how's gum rose my spirit path welcome oh
[ __ ] me let's get back into YouTube
ville so if you bros one and show you
support in this series this could be a
series I want to create two new people
maximum in each episode and then try and
actually play the game I [ __ ] around
with the editor a lot but I want to play
with the actual game hey behind you too
bill posh moving fast so I made a
mistake they have to be adults to live
alone so I'm just really quickly gonna
create me in mad SIA before take a good
look bros before after mafia is done now
let's create me really quick there we
are such a beautiful couple and we just
take a moment and appreciate how
beautiful I am
let's move in amazing
Smita watch as I play this game so if
I'm terrible LEM I'm sure you'll let me
know anyway thanks by the way
oh hello what are we doing oh we like
each other oh my god it's destined to
happen who wouldn't love that beautiful
face what it was my own idea doing that
sign Maya and yes like what the [ __ ]
stop at my you grotesque appeased please
you're ruining the backyard they don't
even know about it
I'm gonna have to decorate our house
it's my duty okay they have that
everything basic to live and might not
be pretty
it might not be the best but it's
something
let's see them appreciate she's like
[ __ ] yeah that chair and I'm like [ __ ]
yeah that chair and she's like [ __ ] yeah
light table and I'm like [ __ ] yeah that
table we sure love we shall just love
table okay whatever doing I don't punch
the puncher this is just like real life
she makes me do this all the time now my
turn
oh so dumb as if this wasn't weird
enough haha
my eye is so big the shadow just can't
handle it
EDI don't you dare poop inside I swear
to god I'll kill you
Maya what are you doing don't you the
furniture they're ruining my furniture
stop having fun there we go Maya how
could you who she floor banya Maya where
the [ __ ] is that guy rod humble is not
very humble you don't just walk through
someone's house all right I think that
we need some neighbors here in this
European town house that looks actually
a lot better than our house get damaged
we should have bought that way let's
create cry looks just like him
I mean oops I like the thing cry looks
like this you can't really change skin
color here Kenny can choose makeup I am
I'm not sure which makeup cry uses to be
honest but I think it's something like
this wait he can pierce his nips oh no
this is ears it looks like nips for me
and then God I thought he had a junk
piercing for a second all right let's
get that face going be ever so handsome
cry cry and let's not forget cinnamon
toast kin that is practically him can
did you swallow the bees did you swallow
them I knew it and of course they have
together adopted a little baby which
will be mix she's a very nice bolt in
I'll give her that
there's no denying that all right that's
good enough for me oh that's adorable
cries holding minks let's make them move
in the cry family they're gonna hit me
they don't have a lot of money but they
have a lot of love oh my God look who
moved in next door oh my god the abuse
couple ever not saying that to be mean
hey cry is a great ass do I have to
design their house as well
god damn it there's a lot of time
setting up this gay man gay man couple
I get this and you know that's it can
they go and visit neighbors and stuff in
this game I'm gonna make cannon cry a
couple that's our first goal here today
flirt
let's caress him now don't go away
now he needs to put down minx stay there
minx we're just gonna flirt there we go
very nice very nice indeed all right
start up good he just wants to backrub
Oh shush minx you're ruining the ships
the ship is sinking coz of you makes oh
can can what are you doing Ken why is he
speaking French I'm trying to get a good
angle on this it's really hard l minx
don't you dare interrupt alright uh okay
minx you need to minx goddamn your mink
a serenade what is that
what that is not a serenade everyone has
pillow fights outside in their backyard
this is this is normal nothing to see
here
I like how the postman just ignores us
it's like yeah I didn't see anything
romantic kiss let's see how that goes
yeah sorry Ken it's busy digging up the
backyard while karai is waiting for a
kiss don't know cry you have to get
kissed come on
mm the ships the ships goddamn you makes
you're always interrupting everything
what is this rob handle guy who is this
main why is it ringing the door when
we're obviously there Rob humble you
stupid let's head over to the normal
family the normal couple there we go
what are we doing here
whose ring into the word attack Edgar
attack Cal might say ignores the obvious
neighbor pretends she doesn't say oh
look it's my eye socket pretend she
doesn't see him interplays with that gay
Maya sees her though I'll poor Maya she
wants the attention
Oh
since likewise never play with me just
because I'm fat doesn't mean I don't
have feelings can we build a pool for
them our backyard is kind of small but
all right might say get in the pool
let's get in the pool
come on she's too scared
really really lose its attack Maya
attack I'm surprised where it's still
alive at this point to be honest oh oh
oh they're here they're here cries here
Oh iced tea
all right great cry and I'll I'll ask to
play Marco Polo
where the [ __ ] that can go he just ran
away uh what did they do
ask cry to join yeah I don't know how he
heard me but it must be my frog senses
oh I'm going out now it's been great
crying a lot of fun today let's play a
prank on on them on my tear I actually
found it I kind of practice that
where's cry oh no cry he went home it's
like I have better things to do than
hang out with these
oh my you need to stop doing that Oh
cries back rise back um say goodbye to
cry me and cry are having an great
conversation about pearls and nothing
else
hey oh no I'm getting jealous
whoa cried smooth guy I'm gonna end this
episode here will they return will they
not no one knows
thank you for leaving like on this
episode and thank you for showing your
support letsa bro
and see in the next one bro finished